today's video is sponsored by surf shark
pretty i know you were good about to get
a a firearm he appeared in canada but
thanks to justin trudeau he's put on a
bane on all the access to handguns no
reselling no selling no acquiring none
of that and so what is this gonna do for
you
well i'm not able to get a handgun
i'm gonna get raffles though
but the thing is the thing is this
they've been trying to do something a
lot of things with gun violence and [ __ ]
a lot of things because you know gun
violence happening and stuff like that
and it increased in the past couple of
months especially here in montreal and
urban centers and stuff like that
justin trudeau is
has got to be
one of the biggest virtual
signal virtualer
virtue signaler
uh
virtue i want to look good this guy
wants to look good he wants to pass it
as it look good does he really want to
do the work not really this guy is
exactly what a guy that put implants for
abs
he want to look good don't want to do
the actual work that's him that's justin
trudeau that's what he does okay because
what has happened happening in montreal
and
in canada
if there's been gun violence
with firearms but the public is not
informed of how you get a firearms and
what's happening in those those firearms
are acquired illegally
you know what i heard ee illegally you
know what i heard the kids in the
streets give me two seconds and you tell
me what i heard what you heard what you
what you what you heard after the kids
in the street
are printing the guns that's what i
heard
they're printing the guns yeah yeah
that's not purchased the printing they
have the patents to print guns and they
print the gun parts and they put them
together
when you put laws on people that buy
guns and go at the shooting range and we
can only go to the shooting range i
can't protect i can't protect my house i
can't open carry concealed carry none of
that i just go to the range to be clear
when you own a firearm in canada the way
it works is very different than the
states you have to keep your firearm in
one safe with a set of locks in
combination on the firearm and then the
ammunition in a different safe with a
different lock and combination your
chargers cannot be charged your
ammunition all the ammo have to be
outside in another box yes so whenever i
lock my firearms in one locker i could
put the chargers there but they has no
ammunition in them so i have to unlock
my safe take my firearm unlock my
firearm take my charger go to my
ammunition case unlock that [ __ ] take
out the box of the proper ammunition
with the proper gun load the i'm dead
i'm not protecting my house with that so
that's fine we took that now you want to
restrict all that what do you think is
going to happen
nothing except the people that are
paying for it and the people that are
actually
abide law-abiding citizens that just do
that for
leisure we're going to get restricted
and the problem is not going to be
solved people are like yeah he's doing
them he's doing it he's doing everything
that he's supposed to do the restrict
that's not where the firearms are there
video is brought to you by surfsharkvpn
a vpn is an application or an extension
that you put on top of your browser in
order to change or to mask your ip
address you know to change the location
of your computer why would you want to
do that well sometimes i want to listen
to other content from other country and
they won't let me in knock knock who's
there canada won't let you in unless
you're from the uk
switch the vpn changer and then boom
knock knock who's there
it's actually the uk now
yes come in lord come have some fee i
know you guys don't speak like that but
you know what i mean so you're able to
watch much more content and then boom
the world is open to you just like
aladdin on a carpet i can show you the
world and for the next month you have 83
off and the three but next month's three
if you use abba and preach code a search
vpn use the link below go ahead
and then people are going to say that
you know what we had a couple of we had
a couple of mass shootings and stuff
like that not as much as the states we
had a couple of mass shootings and stuff
like that and it was legally purchased
firearms concur i concur those
two three people that did that concur
during the covid
there's been a lot of uh there's been a
lot of uh
well uh
domestic boo-boos
right okay we say that there's been a
lot of domestic boo-boos
man acting up and stuff like that and
deleting their partners with knives
stabbings
there's been a lot more stabbings
than mass shootings
so we should just because i could i
could walk inside a walmart every time
everybody people talk every time people
talk about texas they're like you could
walk inside a walmart and purchase a gun
i could walk inside a walmart and
purchase a knife yeah but i think what
they would argue is that the utility of
a knife outweighs
what damage you could do meaning that
but now you have different uses than
just like going to murder people same
with cars whereas guns just have one
tool or this one used as mostly and i
understand what you're saying but
there's been there's been more damage
with those knives that have more usage
than mass shootings right right but what
i'm trying to say is like these items
yeah firearms specifically they would
argue yeah that there's only one use for
them i understand and their ability to
do damage with them is
exponentially high i understand that but
there's been more damage that's been
done with the knives
with there's been more and the damage
that is done with the guns are illegal
so restricting that there is not the
problem do you know that in montreal
last year in october
the police called the mafia they called
the mafia to help them with the gun
situation in this crete that means that
they don't have control over what's
going on and restricting legal
legal guns
is not where the guns are coming from
they're printing the [ __ ] yeah so i
think the main issue here
is
the use of what is a real problem
i.e um the use of firearms and a lot of
criminal activity
and then linking that to
the purchasing the sale of firearms
it's like well no these two things are
not linked and so when you try to cover
up the fact that you're being
ineffective with one issue by doing
listing again it does just seem like yo
i heard what happened in the states i
saw the shooting we gonna ban these guns
but what does that have to do with the
real problems that we have here
and i think what you see a lot with this
prime minister specifically is that a
lot of the policies and the things that
he does is just for optics sake it
doesn't really have anything to do
of anything substantial now most people
who do not want to see the gun violence
that exists in america come to canada
would say yeah still we don't want that
here and i can understand that sentiment
me personally seeing all these shootings
i'm like i'm trying to raise my kids in
america that's crazy you got to worry
about how you kids
somebody blowing up your spot like
that's insane to me i get that
but at the same time let's not
let's not jump to the wrong conclusions
and not deal with the real problems
because what ends up happening is you
misinform the public the public probably
doesn't know that these young people who
are here shooting up the streets are
using 3d printers you guys probably
don't know that
so that's my issue with this whole thing
it's like
you are misdirecting from what's really
the problem and then trying to score
political points and everybody go wow
and then the problem still exists
so
that's why i find this whole thing
distasteful
yeah so
you're not you're not solving the
problem it really looks like you're
solving the thing
to the people that don't know you look
like you're doing oh you're doing the
best thing and you're so careful but
you're not you're not you make it look
like it's it's you're caring and
everything but you're not really
tackling the problem in the shoot the
issue where it is yeah you want to keep
the money elsewhere you want to put that
elsewhere that that what you're doing
right now
passing laws costs less money than
actually dealing with the problem
you're going to do that you're going to
pass the law okay no no no restricted
weapons
allow and the problem is still not going
to change but it's going to take some
time for the public to realize it facts
facts let us know what you guys think in
the comments we want to hear from you